[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
third episode of Queen trap psych lines
in this episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful Queen trap line in the Richter
rouser attack of the classical Sicilian
from the white perspective the opening
arises after the following order
efore c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 pawn takes
d4 Knight takes d4 Knight to f6
attacking e4 Knight to c3 defending and
now the characteristic classical
Sicilian move Knight to c6 amongst all
white reply
I think Richter rouser attack is one of
the most attacking set up and it
comments with the move Bishop to g5 so
if allowed then white is certainly going
to double black pawn so accordingly
black needs to stop it with the moon c6
and now white will play Queen to d2 so
you can see the simple attacking scheme
by wide wide wants to quickly castle on
the Queen side and then launch
devastation on the black King side with
this pawn strong okay mainline mu
continue with the move Bishop to e7
castle on the Queen side and now black
castle on the Kings side so it's
opposite side Castle scenario where
every single attacking move counts or
not white plays the obvious move have
four so not only grabbing space on the
King side but there is a threat in the
position that is Knight capture c6 and
then the movie file so something black
needs to pay attention immediately the
mainline continue with the Moon Knight
captures D form
Quinn captures d4 so still black is
having some problem on the D file and
that's why clean - EFI is a fitting
reply now the main line here continue
with the move Bishop to c4 but as usual
I'm going to show you a very surprising
move in this position which creates the
platform for our queen trap line my
recommendation is you go with the movie
file so white is attacking two spots
so black responses force black has to
capture the spawn and afterwards we are
going to capture with our queen so you
can already see what is attacking the
Queen and if black exchanged the Queen
then the resulting position is slightly
better for the white so many black
players and especially if they are
attacking player then they will
certainly avoid the Queen trail and
accordingly as for the database
second-highest choice by the black ace
Queen to b6 well at first sight
everything looks so normal but blacks
last move as a big time mistake before
I'm on I like you to pause this video
and find out a sequence where actually
you can win blacks queen or win blacks
heavy material
okay let's see how accurate your
sequence is the first important move I
think you already guessed it that is
Knight to e4 so now this Queen has the
only two spots to go and wherever she
goes black will get a lost position for
example the first move I want to
consider it is Queen to f2 well after
that just one move rook to d2 and the
sweetie is trapped right there engineer
suggesting black should give up the
Queen and capture the rook but in case
if you are wondering what happens if you
open and counter-attack your queen with
Knight to g4 well then it's not hard to
spot it because after rook captures f2
Knight captures efile and Bishop
captures a7 y teamers with a whole extra
piece I think Queen to c6 is a more
critical response in this position after
that another piece join in to the tag
Bishop to b5 once again queen has the
only move Queen captures g2 but before
we look at it we should obviously see
what happens if you open and
counter-attack your queen with any
knight move
the first knight who I want to consider
is Knight to g4 well after that the
sequence is very easy we are going to
play Quint we - so two pieces are
hanging and black cannot save both of
them so after Queen to c7 Bishop capture
c7 Queen capture c7 and Queen captures
g4 Whitely merged with an extra piece
and instead of Knight to g4 if you open
and continue here with Knight to d7 then
more or less same story in this case e
seven bishop will hang after queen tweto
so considering all the right options it
is very obvious that black has to move
the Queen and Queen captures g2 is
forced in this position
well after that White has a very easy
move rook to Jeevan now this Queen has
four squares to go but it doesn't matter
wherever she goes either black going to
lose her queen or completely lose a
piece so let's check them by clockwise
the first more I want to consider this
Queen to history well after that white
task is quite easy boom so black is
going to lose whole piece if he's going
to save his Queen well same goes for the
Queen captures s2 because this pin is
very deadly and in fact cost apiece the
third option is Queen to f2 but it
doesn't look good either as white is
keep attacking this Queen with rook d2 F
1 and now black has nothing better than
capturing the rook as after Queen
captures as true the same fitting reply
Bishop captures f6 and black is going to
lose a whole piece
finally what happens if you open in
place Queen to f3
well at first sight this looks more
safer spot but after rook to g3 black
has to surrender his queen in both the
moves Queen to h5 and Queen to f4
completely fails to the tactics of
Bishop to f6 and if he open and continue
with the move Queen to f2 now then after
rook to d2 black queen is a complete
corner well I hope you enjoy along this
wonderful Queen treppie line in the
victor rouser attack thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care